mixing does this make any sense to you
think real hard
think harder
harder
[Music]
harder
did your brain explode this is getting
weird now how does blood get here hmm
this is strange a puzzle's a foot
there's really only one way that a large
amount of blood gets on the ground
and uh
well i mean you could guess what it is
lixian show him a demonstration unless
that's too hard to animate and then
don't
don't you dare unless you want to
and in that case who am i to stop your
creativity
i'm not an animator i don't know how bad
or hard that is to do
i appreciate you
do what you want
oh
i will look at the phone yes there yes
hello editor
you hear that lixie you're demoted to
editor again
i'm sorry oh my god it's smart
now while you're gone with the crowd are
you a large pile of data
lit hey whoa elixir please oh hello hi
[Music]
sorry to run it you don't accord man if
someone came down the stairs and ran
full sprint straight at me after walking
i'd be pissing my pants gear alexia run
at me as fast as you can it's pretty
scary
pretty scary thank you alexian can you
uh actually play that play that audio in
reverse
speed it up
slow down
double it
and now decode it and translate it in
the bottom
okay thank you for that now everybody
knows press control that is a weird
thing to graffiti on a board i should do
that oh my god we should totally do that
we should just start graffiti
instructions for like keyboard controls
but out in real life so people get
confused
oh my god how bad would that mess with
someone's mind if they were just out in
the forest and it said press shift to
run
do it do that thing do the thing do that
thing do that thing
we're gonna do that then go out and do
the thing murdered here
all right interesting
hi what is it
mom can i go to lose a halloween party
have you finished all your tasks i'm
almost finishing you can go when you
finish them and take your brother with
you why do i need to take this idiot
with me why do i need to take this idiot
with me
sorry
you can join
it's fine it's fine everybody shush i'm
concentrating everyone be quiet
especially you lexan you be quiet elixir
and be quiet everyone
tells you to be quiet right now he's
judging me harshly and i can't i can't
handle that i won't handle it i refuse
to handle it
i can almost see something moving in the
holes don't look in the holes
what's the first rule finding a bunch of
holes in the random
uh lexian could you reboot me real quick
thank you lexi and make me look good
[Laughter]
thank you
anyway look see make sure the brightness
matches through the whole video
very sure that these
you couldn't see through these before so
bright brighten it up a bit more come on
bring the brightness up
blast it come on blast me but make me
look good
make me look good perfect where is this
resemblance i see more seth rogen in
this dude than me i'm not saying that
this dude is horrendously disfigured and
ugly but also just what the poop
elixie and censor that oh lexi just put
in a distractible promo here i can't
even i need a few minutes i need like a
minute okay just put a nice distractible
promo okay make it really nice in
explosions lots of explosions okay cool
tell them about the link in the
description there's gonna be a link in
the description
more explosions
lincoln is in the blues
link is in the lyxia point where it is
it's down there
go check out more videos that i made
okay
good thank you
flexion give him a smooch
come on
give us a better deal
okay thank you thank you could have been
on the lips but whatever you know i'm
not gonna judge is that supposed to be a
mouse in the background because
i'm not gonna lie just looking at it
right now it looks a lot like a douche
lexian put up a side by side so people
don't think i'm crazy anyway don't put
in my react i don't know do whatever you
want lexie and i i'm
i'm not the boss of you
not safe for work mode
you have not enabled safer work mode
yeah
oh yeah
this is fine
oh yeah i don't know what that means but
lexi and you may have to censor
something
aggressively more more censorship
put boobs under it and then censor it
for god's sake censor it now it's been
many years since i last played hoonie
pop back before you litzy and you
weren't even here
it was matt watson
matt watson edited this but avert your
eyes this isn't for the impure or this
is for the pure this is impure don't
look at the boobs
my god don't look at the boobs you shush
lixie and cover up all the noises
make it pg make it make it make it fine
it's all good it's okay it's all good
it's okay
[Applause]
take it out get it away go put it away
take it away
i detect something here there's
something going on here i sensitive
in the air i feel it i can tell i got a
sixth sense about these things you two
want
boom you got i am i write or am i right
about that listen back me up on this one
you're you're you're picking
i'm sorry
[Music]
i i'm i don't know
i get demonetized you know i just i lose
it
anyway avert your eyes you shouldn't be
watching this and then i can't give you
the passion but i can give you the
passion definitely or the passion
fashion
no
sucker the
vivacity whatever that is i don't i
for some reason i'm blanking on the name
but you guys know what i'm talking about
right like saying you know what i'm
talking about right good great thank you
so you need to keep it in your pants you
don't have pants literally
i'm begging you
i'm just
every time i look down i'm like
[Music]
is that a penis is this a penis is this
a penis is that a penis lyxian d blur
this photo do it
do it
[Music]
people are that photo
i want to see it with my own eyes
gross
hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to three
scary
games
i'm assuming that elixion just doesn't
want to make those sound effects so i
made them for him so
make that sound good there lexie and
scare him good you know how this is
don't give me any says
[Music]
i'll leave
by the way congratulations
did you say take it did i get a whisper
saying take it lixian did you say take
it i should take it are you saying that
i should take it so you can go any which
away you can go every which away
uh lixian please add a nice sound effect
when the cauldron goes boosh
i don't know why but i'm very suspicious
about what you're gonna add and i won't
know until the video comes out
i'm sure it's fine
all right
i trust you
lexian
you believe me don't you
good
very good gotta say
fascinating aesthetics
got it lexie did you say cut it
this guy is a drug dealer it may not
look like it but i deal in drugs drugs
you want them i got them drugs you need
drugs i seed out into the world i grow
from seeds i don't do drugs myself i
don't use what i grow i don't grow i
don't um there's a saying for that this
is terrible lexi and fix this so it's
all better or just start it over please
hi my name is markiplier and i've never
done drugs
that you know of
read it
okay
okay now you're welcome to watch because
before you definitely
okay well now you're able to watch
because definitely before you were not
welcome to because if you were watching
before you weren't watching at the right
time and then
lixie and bro oh blixian probably didn't
uh edit it properly which you know
lixian uh you know not the
not the most uh attention to
detail-oriented person you know and i
mean we all know lixie and uh
you know uh just always letting things
slip
lexi and just cut all around this so it
makes it look like i figured it out
right off the bat you know what i mean
you know what i'm saying what am i
supposed to do now i thought i'd go get
the gun
and now i have the gun
lexington cut ahead until i'm smart
again
oh oh what if i shoot that
oh
there we go oh you're down baby yeah
thank goodness i got that on the first
try lick cna thanks for uh being such a
great editor and not telling anybody of
any secret things that we uh don't talk
about
thanks pal
lexie and cut all this out
cut everything out cut cut the whole
intro just cut it out man just really
cut it out man
cut it out man let's cut it out
stop it
get some help alexian fbi is going to
break in
fbi open up
please put in the comments your papers
that show that you're allowed to be here
along with your work permit your travel
visa your passport all your information
don't actually put your information in
the
comments
or do don't actually don't but in this
hypothetical scenario do don't don't
actually what have i done could all no
don't cut but do but don't ah i'll leave
it to you listen whatever legal
ramifications happen to me or on your
shoulders okay it's all on you buddy
it's all on you
i trust you
and all legal ramifications are on
lixie's shoulders okay cool thanks all
right let's excuse me excuse me i got to
record a video i was hoping for like a
big 10 v10 but let's do a 3v3 we'll see
what happens probably nothing impressive
or maybe it will be but i'll always have
lixie in there to make it look
impressive no matter what right lexian
you'll cut it together to make it look
like i win every time right lexie and
please make me look smarter please i'm
begging you make me look better than
that thank you
you always do right by me
apprecia
wow
unless you didn't
i could have lexie and edit out all my
mistakes i could have it happen
he'd do that for me
he'd do that for me
i know he would
right
you'd do that for me
thanks for making me look so good high
five oh boom i'm gonna assume that you
definitely made me look good right
otherwise that high five would be
completely unwarranted
[Music]
josh shush it's a good looking it's
going to cover all my mistakes that's a
good thing literally it's not going to
make me look stupid in front of the
internet
there's also a different
thing
so
why
what is there no audio to this hammer it
there's no audio
uh lixian replace all these sound
effects with uh you making the sounds
with your mouth
do it i i command thee to do it
thank you like why is this teaching
children how to make a homemade knife i
feel like this is highly irresponsible
alexian i hope you're still making the
sound effects just reuse reuse if you
don't feel like
going the distance
i thought you wanted these videos to be
high quality you know i thought i
thought that maybe you know you would
lay it all on the left side
it really is relying on you
all of this is relying on you that is a
quality knife this is a great knife i
can please sing all around me our
familiar faces
mad world you know the one oh my god
all around me are familiar
but also make the piano your
voice as well and if you didn't do it
before now redo it
now
with leave what you did before already
and do it
please
i'm sorry you don't have to do it
i'm sorry
[Music]
don't even worry about cutting out too
much of this you can really leave in
quite a bit you know even slow down some
of the time lapses i know these are
notes that i could have given to you at
any point in the editing process
and i didn't
that's because i am a bad youtuber who
does not communicate well to their
editors and i will try better in the
future and i really appreciate
everything that you rachel and marcus do
but if you could make it a little better
that'd be great thank you
is there no sound yeah there's just no
sound there's no sound uh lixian
i know an easy way to do this a super
easy way to do it we have in premiere
you have multiple like audio tracks and
you've got the record button right there
you just record right to it you do the
first take you don't do any second takes
because why would you do that you're
perfect the first time you're perfect
the first time you're perfect the first
time you're perfect the first time
so if you could just get that done quick
now that'd be great i want to make sure
that it's actually ruined
alexia make sure you did you get the
blue wings did you get that
did you get the eyes bulging sound
effects
did you do it
good good i'm not awake that was it i
got it i don't need to look again and i
won't look again lixian proved that i
won't look again by removing my eyes
and everyone watching is already left
because now they are bored they can edit
it out mark you know you know you can do
that you can edit out
very
yeah
to also
keep every single detail in he keeps
coming to me with this like portuguese
accent like oh please don't let do this
to us and then i'm like you gotta do it
you portuguese man portuguese is old to
peace don't do this
oh no
lexie and tv
what deck are we playing today mark
we're playing
lucian what deck are we playing and say
it in the accent
[Laughter]
there's a whole mini map there's a mini
oh there's a may or may not be covered
by our faces depending where you want to
squeeze you in uh lixie and make sure
it's as covered as possible
oh no we were one book away and we had
it
yeah let's just uh pretend like we did
have it
oh yeah
[Music]
what what do they call that i there's
another word it's like it not in
memoriam it's not a memorialization
i don't know someone on someone in the
comments you know what lixie and look up
the word put it on the screen you know
how english isn't your first language
like saying you know this word look at
you know this one you know what we're
talking about look at you and your funny
little animation that you you bob it in
your head and then yeah
and then
don't make fun hey actually interact
with them like pokemon pokemon you can
poke them
yeah it feels powerful right
all right now elixie and do it do a
classic unis honest outro where the sun
hits us and it explodes and then the
aliens come down and they they take our
bodies up into space but then a part of
us is still alive and we explode the
ship from the inside and there's a
spiral into a black hole okay all right
lacy you you heard that uh make marcus
do it okay cool all right thank you
[Music]
luxian don't put any of this in i'm just
waiting i don't have any others to look
at you better not be putting this in
wham
you better not boom
don't put this in bam
don't try it
don't put it in do you think it's wrong
for an endless person to get murdered
no
i see the son of the devil is finally
upon me
if i appeared behind you right now would
you scream yeah in
a power scream as i grab you in the
throat sorry
lexie i really do wonder was this
practical like did people you know did
people you know
you know like
you know sorry alexian maybe i should
play like
this lexi and look most your job's
already taken from you
all right whatever
all right whatever that's fine
look look santa didn't i didn't mean i'm
sorry i'm sorry it's all good don't
worry don't get stressed i also know
that webcam positioning and zoom is very
inconvenient for you lixian but you're
just gonna have to deal with it there is
no room for you in this box so don't
even try to get in here because
i can't deal with your sass right now
so don't even think about being sassy to
me because i'm not going to take it
not today
why'd you do that hey look it was all
jokes man i didn't mean it i didn't have
to
move my ball oh wow my god hi
this is for tricking me to eat that
so-called oh
ow
ouch ouch ow
safely and earn as many points as
possible
lixian this looks like a game you might
have made
you remember did you uh steal the idea
from them i don't care if this game came
out after you made your game that i
definitely remember the name of it oh
god please look oh god what was it
what was the name of it whoa
what was the name of your game you're a
great game it was it was a good game i
liked it i did a video on it
not the game that you made for me oh
oh
what was it
shmoophams it was called shmoop'em ups
oh
no
oh that the log
blast ass i think it was called blast
ass i'm gonna go blast ass all right if
you remember ultimate epic battle
simulator one
did i ever
did i make a video on up ultimate epic
battle sim did i
listen did i make a video on
i think i did thank you but i think i
did i appreciate it i know you went to
the effort of getting that but to be
perfectly honest now i'm rejecting it
because i think i did and i'm going to
believe that i did
thank you for having the proof but i'm
not gonna look at it
i don't need to do that with all the
self-confidence i have in myself
wow
hey hi
hello
oh god you're quick hi no
oh oh
the only reason that this is so crap is
because it's very late at night
i didn't have a lot of time to set up
anything there's no quality in this and
i know that elixir in here to make it
all better he's going to give you one
reason why you should have any sort of
pity on me right about now it's your
chance lexie here you go
go on speak right into the microphone
tell them how you really feel about me
come on don't be shy
[Music]
of spooky amp up the spookage
i don't know what that means but just go
ahead and try oh you did it you did the
thing
oh lexie and you're good
lexie and you're real good you're so
good at your job i should give you a
raise
that was incredible
how have you started to do effects right
when i'm playing
before you even know
weird
not gonna look into it too much oh hi
it's a little quiet here lixie and put
in some music
some scare sorry scary music
scarier
[Music]
good that's good that's good
listen closely
i'm trying man
cranking
oh my god bad time to crank it
well i can't move
oh
oh
oh god hi
hello
photo from the internet perhaps peter
sherman saw something similar it looks
creepy
yeah no joke what's with the music
lixie and what have i told you about
playing music in the background while
i'm doing things it makes me on edge hey
look scene can you amp up that spookage
really
really appreciative if you could
come on lexian i know you can do it
come on
lexie and amp up the spookage
amp it up
[Music]
amp it up anything under the bed
wardrobe is empty there's a
no
oh my god i will punch you
i'm coming in to punch
that's not what i would call a good
sound houston you're hearing this lexian
you're in houston command do you hear
any of this
okay all right admission uh continue
mission has as described thank you
lixian i will not let you down um okay
let's see my brother lives in apartment
24. if only i brought my glasses i can't
really read those numbers from here
uh 24 i hope it's not the flickering one
here's 20.
knock
anybody seen my brother this is dark
well it just ends there so that's fine
oh my camera's gone
well that's inconvenient lexian put up a
uh artist rendition of my face no need
to animate the mouth or anything like
that unless you could do just a quick
automated to my voice signal thing wave
form whatnot whatever if that's too much
work abandon the process
and
never even remember that i asked to do
it in the first place and berate me
heavily insult me hello
lixian you know she kind of looks a bit
like you
the resemblance is uncanny
no
i can't tell the difference
hi
alexian please tone down the spookage it
is too spooky
hold it down what are you doing um still
don't like what i'm looking at gonna
turn my tail and run
uh houston once again if you could get
the heavy duty underwear i'm going to
need that upon arrival thank you lixian
you're the best all right oh
[Laughter]
my my you got
got some schmutz on your face listen now
the the resemblance is uncanny
you're beautiful god uh let's you just
get it over with uh
thank you and as always i'll see you in
the next one
bye-bye
[Applause]
i don't know if this by the same person
that made that convenience store game
i can't remember what it is lexian
helped me out inject it into my brain
and then shoot it out my eyeballs
i'm really sorry that i've been asking
you to do such complex things and i'm
sure that you went above and beyond with
that effect and everyone is really
impressed by it i just want to say thank
you
so much
[Music]
thanks
also lixian feel free to completely
ignore everything i'm asking you to do
i don't know
if this is too too cumbersome just i buy
paul i
apologize i'm sorry i'm sorry i'm sorry
psych
short sweet to the point uh but seem to
be lacking a big jump scare finish so
lexian can you hit him with a big jump
scare finish so we can move on to the
next game okay thanks i'll leave you to
it all right have fun
[Music]
did you do the big no what's that oh
oh
oh i'm sorry
i'll go
no i'll go i'll go i'll come back later
no you can still do it it'll still be
good it'll be a big finish
but i'm gonna go so you can do it but
it'll be fine it'll be just scary
i'm sorry
uh i'm gonna leave okay all right bye
bye sorry bye
[Music]
just wanted to say again i'm kind of
sorry
sorry